during a Roundtable discussion with the
podcast skytalkers John Favreau made
some interesting comments that indicated
grogu and the Mandalorian had been
traveling together for years before the
finale of season two it's also implied
grogu spent years in Jedi training with
Luke Skywalker before returning to
denjarin Favreau explained he started
off earlier in the Jedi Temple and then
we know that he's been rescued and spent
many years with the Mandalorian went
back with Luke now we've been two years
apart from him there training favro's
comments imply that all of the
Mandalorian season 1 and 2 takes place
over many years which is not directly
addressed in the show it also implies
the time Jump between season 2 and the
Book of Boba Fett is two years long
while the exact timeline of the
Mandalorian remains unclear favreau's
use of many years certainly makes it
seem like grogu and dinjarin spent more
time together than actually seen in the
Mandalorian what kinds of Adventures
have we missed